[Music]
and most search news o excluding porn oh
no it's including porn submitted by your
loving fans hey thank you are they gonna
tell us all the things that are
searching the interwebs pornhub has
released their annual review of what
porn was watched the most in 2017 was it
interesting I love this [ __ ] can I guess
good incest porn
not that I'm into it but it's been
popping a lot no I'm not I've been
getting a lot of recommended ass for it
those are targeted but target but Gina
has been telling me because she has
friends that work in a porn industry not
that she's a porn star
but her friend that I met who watches
porn who works as I think marketing in
porn or whatever but he says that it's
porn meet marketing hell yeah I met a
guy who watches porn who says that the
insert they probably have their own SEO
team and everything oh where do they
mark in other incest stuff is really hot
right now this is marketing all right
so pornhub these are the top searches of
2017 hmm wha they look it looks not porn
ish at all
Rick and Morty yeah point for women was
number one for women it's just like
audible.com it just called what did you
say what did you say like audible.com
like listening like it's like I'm
hearing you baby I've seen stupid uh
like they'll say porn for women and it's
like a guy cleaning the house I'm like
[ __ ] you uh yeah I've seen porn for
women it's it's got like a little story
and also the lighting is very soft and
it looks kind of like I should boring
yeah exactly
but good for though it they build it up
kids so it's like a hallmark movie until
it we have to be invested in their
backstory yes we care there's a story
like like she's a secretary for this
famous actor and she just moved to
California and then like it's better
than other porn I literally when I watch
porn I skip to the part where like the
guys about to come I skip all the way to
like all right become
no no I skipped it right before it like
like right like what he's like yeah like
that kinda [ __ ] like what he's like oh
guys [ __ ] jealous or what I don't
need a backstory I don't need like yeah
I forward all that [ __ ] like get to the
part where like you're comfortable like
getting really mad and angry and the
testosterone II I only watch this [ __ ]
where they throw the girls out of the
vans and throw money at them they throw
her out of the van that they just
[ __ ] like chuck money at her head
like the girls are they have the same
reaction they're like feel like they're
both like you know like what oh [ __ ]
they're acting yeah yeah oh it's not
real no it's not real it's a great
acting no it's not real they have
formats so they have show formats right
and the Bing bat bus format is oh here's
this random hot girl in a Skippy that
does it we're problem or anywhere in the
middle a day she's just showing her and
if she's magically shaving and ready to
[ __ ] Hanabusa perfectly clean yeah yeah
but these top searches I love that
record morning yeah rigor mortis number
two definitely contributed to that what
is that what is it like what's Rick and
Morty porn Ricky wait that's the porn
no it means pop searches period right I
know I look oh I just looked up regular
Rick and Morty not are you sure
we need the time that's a grandpa and
his sign I would not look at right yeah
that's the top porn okay I got confused
if I was just google search in general
but pornhub is that's interest like you
Morty porn yeah that's why I would that
look like what is that
I've seen spy seen spin spin report it's
[ __ ] review week Google Cleary then
they spit yeah all that girls are like
[ __ ] and holding it here and it's
like spinning while they're getting like
butt [ __ ] and [ __ ] and I'm all like
that is weird so pornhub is this like a
who puts a teepee in the search there
are people that love that's true
I want to see the zits on the chicks ass
dude I'm sure they already light it like
a [ __ ] drugstore and then they got it
like put the light right up or ass or
whatever likes you can see every
imperfection it's pretty not suitable
and then ASMR hentai I don't have any
zits on my ass no I know you don't
okay porn ladies always do I was just
trying to imagine sits on someone's ass
and I'm like I don't think I've ever
they might be ingrown hair from the
constant shavings you shave your ass I
know that that's what it sounded like
well maybe a pointy shoe no look it's an
ingrown hairs okay
not everybody has a first queen great
time with it yeah the last one here is
cheerleader so oh yeah yeah that's where
the top searches bartson top searches
real estate lady it's real estate lady
and this white lady you don't search
pressings I just found out that it
turned me on but I don't search for pink
so what part is you just watching them
on the toilet or what's the hot part Oh
was i searching for peeing women again
what for a barbell video about girls
that listen oh I was looking for that I
was looking for a thumbnail yeah and
then I started looking up girls peeing
and I started turned me on
so now if I exert too much energy
exercising I found those this common
with a lot of you pee a little bit yeah
I didn't know that didn't happen to guys
you're a normal thank you nice I'm not
great yeah so the next one here we have
is the most searched-for terms of 2017
so the top line is lesbian number two
hentai number three milf
what's hentai it's cartoon porn like
anime yeah the enemy oh okay Homer Marge
I'm talking about
I've seen those idols are weird [ __ ]
weird right oh yeah we seen that it's
like Marge with a [ __ ] dick in her
mouth it's me yeah it's Marge and like
Bo's [ __ ] her mouth or something it's
weird that is some weird with my
childhood like that
I know yeah I know that's weird you
watched it no that kind of stuff does
not turn me on
just the incest stuff the search for
porn stars here the top one is Riley
Reid where does that say Kim Kardashian
yeah Riley Reid is this one Mia Khalifa
is this girl she was like top like a
couple years ago I think you know I went
to high school with the girl that looked
exactly like her but she was she was a
lesbian in high school our friend our
friend hangs out with her yeah hangs out
with Mia mm-hmm one of our stunt friends
chiku
I don't know I never asked she's trying
to get into stunts I don't know trying
to do that movie wait Kim Kardashian
still up there after after we Khalifa is
Lisa and which is this girl I'm so
disconnected with the porn entertainers
these days cuz I don't know these names
well cuz used to have to pay for it so
that you would like certain ones but now
everything's like super free and amateur
porn is everywhere it sounds like you
don't really it's like keeping track of
youtubers yeah no but yeah a fourth
place is Kim Kardashian down one from
last year and she's not even action as a
porn star I know you know you think all
these women are like babe they're trying
to be perfect you know they're
professionals
but then Kim Kardashian just has one sex
tape and she outranks him and can I just
say similar to the Paris Hilton sex tape
the Kim Kardashian sex tape it's posted
on that when I heard that Kim Kardashian
did not know did she didn't know she was
being filmed right no yeah you could see
like oh you can see the video but I've
seen like clips of when Ray J's like I'm
pretty sure she well I think it was
Paris then Paris Hilton I guess didn't
know she was being abused and I was like
I can tell she that she knew she did she
did not know she's new
cuz she would have I think she would
have done a little bit it was like that
in for not infrared but like it was like
dark yeah night-vision [ __ ] it was like
green it was pretty boring remember that
one where the guy had a sex tape with
Britney Spears but he was too scared to
release it cuz he didn't like his
performance in it what that's hilarious
that's funny yeah that was back in that
there's a Britney [ __ ] tape yeah but I
don't think he released it was she ball
well how would he why would he even
really
that information you know like well cuz
he was trying to draw interest and then
he chickened out and he's like I he's
like I have a sex tape and then he was
like and then he's so he's watching it
back and he's like yeah and then fifth
place is sunny lumion
oh she's she's uh been around for a
while I think early 2000 I think yeah I
would be I swear to God never I would
love to do a lie detector show where we
hooked guys up to lie detector test it's
like have you heard of this porn star
and just every single answers like like
no no it's like this every time they was
[ __ ] especially like cuz even just
now I felt like I was lying to you but I
really haven't heard of her no I only
heard of her cuz people used to make
comparisons to me and her before you
said that you gotta look alikes I swear
I have it but nomina I know there's one
that they keep comparing me to and like
they're like photoshopping like my face
over my body and I'm like yeah then they
go with you - yeah the same loser
messaging nobody does that for me
no I wish they did to me I've seen yours
cuz like the girls bodies dope I was
like okay you want to think I asked my
body's like that your body's pretty dope
though come on
thanks babe that's a support hello
where's the [ __ ] compliment babe
what where's the [ __ ] compliment your
body's also I just told you yesterday
thank you
yesterday yesterday 24 hours ago you're
like the five man she's right here
back and forth so many times my mom's
watching her yeah and so these are the
top 20 countries by track what is the
countries what's the US UK oh by a mile
but look at this holy [ __ ] you're
crushing the porn game well at least on
pornhub maybe they have different points
I think Oh Becca me and then the third
place is India then Japan India is
[ __ ] horny yeah
but India's kind of nice because we have
a video of vlog called sex expert and
Gina is on the thumbnail of it and 90%
of our traffic for editing I think has
20 million views it's all from India Wow
there horniest but so Gina's on thumb no
huh yeah we do that sex expert check it
out after India and Japan I think men
are horny [ __ ]
I can't believe India beat Japan why
hornier well they have more people and
make it work don't like they get more
like they're more respectful get ashamed
of like the dance what Japan's like the
[ __ ] nice place in the whole world
maybe the hand type for it I don't know
Japan but jeans Japan doesn't need that
pornhub because they got vending
machines with [ __ ] in it I just think
of all the like Japanese like you know
the like pressure just like you know do
a good job in the world and like that's
why they needed homework yeah but the
way the Japanese are music that's what I
got ball loads do is just like they're
like it's it's naturalized you just need
a like let loose it's like part of the
it's not prude I don't know they're
prudent other things yeah
America need that porn up because we
like to pretend like we're we're totally
cool and innocent people that's why they
love like that's why people love to
watch porn alone unlike a lot of these
countries where they have out yeah I
think yeah because when I was in Japan
there were these little stores right and
in bait they had they block their
entrance and there's like signs 18 or
something and endo be like a hot girl
walking out and I researched online what
that was you didn't walk in no I didn't
walk in a business card not cuz I didn't
know what it was but they're jack off
station
what their what they do is like there's
you have your stalls with tissue or
whatever and then dole just be a girl
like you could watch them they're like
peep shows yeah they're like [ __ ]
masturbating or whatever yeah and then
you just whack off to them what I'll go
peep shows peep shows are nothing here
I think they're illegal wait aren't they
or you're not supposed to jack off in
there like they have them but they
you're not a lot of duck that's the
wiedersehen whether to me dick adult
feeders my Moen remember when pee-wee
Herman got busted for jerking it and up
to a porn movie I was like wait you
can't [ __ ] do that [ __ ] like we're
just supposed to sit there boy have your
arms on the armrest just like oh [ __ ] I
feel like when I when I go to Mexico
everything is like dicks city like it's
just all the little statues are just
like big penis men that one and where is
it Rosarito or something no it's
everywhere every time I've ever been in
Mexico no matter what city I go to it's
not like all my deals head [ __ ] like
that
I'm talking about the touristy places
I've seen it in Hawaii not that tripped
me out Oh house like what the [ __ ] dick
everything that fell crazy
[Music]